- I'm Jovana, Senior Technical
Evangelist at Atlassian.
I specialize in platform engineering
and cloud infrastructure
and also in Rovo Dev
and everything to do
with improving software
development lifecycle.
Let's get into it.
Now, before we do dive in,
let's quickly set the stage.
So, why are developer productivity
and quality so critical?
My favorite explanation to that
is that if you invest in your developers,
they will have better support,
creating better product.
If you have a better product,
your company brings revenue.
It's as simple as that.
And at Atlassian,
we now run Developer Experience report,
and each year we learn something new.
From our 2025 DevEx report,
we've learned that 99%,
so almost every developer,
has reported time savings using AI,
but still is losing time across
auto development lifecycle.
They're only spending
16% of their time coding,
which we all know that's not
the friction for developers.
The other 84% is where
AI tools and assistants
have the real market opportunity
to change that and improve it
because really, developers
are losing valuable time
on non-coding tasks,
and that's exactly what I
wanna talk to you about today.
Software development is
at its core a team effort,
and our vision at Atlassian
is for every software development team
to have a teammate that deeply understands
their organizational context
as it's captured in the
Atlassian Ecosystem,
from Jira issues through Confluence pages,
all the way through the codebases,
wherever those codebases live.
That teammate should be aware
of your engineering history,
including past incidents
and their resolutions.
Now, that intelligent teammate
can put all that
knowledge to work for you,
assisting you wherever you are working,
whether that's a terminal, the ID,
the CI/CD pipelines, or maybe even Jira.
And that teammate can be Rovo Dev,
and I would like to introduce you to it.
Rovo Dev is Atlassian's
AI-powered agent for developers.
It is designed to accelerate
software development lifecycle
all the way through code planning,
code generation, code reviews,
and automation of repetitive tasks
and all that at scale.
It understands both natural
language but also code,
which means you can interact with it
wherever you're working.
It is powered by
Atlassian's Teamwork Graph,
which means it's got context
of all of your data within
the Atlassian Ecosystem.
Now, of all the places that
you can interact with Rovo Dev,
my favorite one is the CLI
because it's meeting me
where I like to work.
It leverages Teamwork Graph,
so I can ensure
that it has all the
right suggestions for me,
it's got all my real context,
and it knows my business.
But let's take a look at it in action.
Now, here is a website
that I created one time,
and we have these speakers
that are all wrong.
Yep, that is me,
Jovana, Senior Technical Evangelist,
but that was not my face.
What I can do is I'm gonna ask
Rovo Dev to fix this for me.
Right now, I've just
authenticated Rovo Dev,
I've gone to my Jira issue
and I've literally just
copied that issue link
and pasted it into Rovo Dev.
Rovo Dev is pulling all that information,
the description,
any other links that I might
have added to this issue
just so it can give me
the best response it can.
Now, it might be leveraging
memory file as well,
depending on what I had added
in that description of the ticket.
If I go back and refresh, it's updated,
and now all of us kind of look
the way we should be looking like.
That is Shane, that is Willer,
and that was me.
Now, one of the cool things
is I can just copy an image,
paste it into Rovo Dev
and let Rovo Dev read the image as is,
detecting what is it that was on the image
so that it can make those changes.
It is that intelligent
that it will recognize
that there are certain
things on that image
that are not supposed to be there,
and it goes on and fixes it.
I'm quickly swapping between the two
just so you see that it's actually updated
exactly what I highlighted
that I need changing on.
Next, we've introduced
an AI-based code reviewer
that is also part of Rovo Dev.
On repositories where Rovo Dev is enabled,
Code Reviewer will automatically run
after your pull request is created.
Code Reviewer spends a few minutes
analyzing the code changes
and then it comments directly
onto your pull request
with all the possible recommendations,
fixes and improvements
that should be made.
It makes comments, including feedback
and things like bugs and maintainability,
readability, security,
and so on and so forth.
And there are ways to
improve your code reviewer
and tailor it to your
specific organizational needs.
Firstly, acceptance criteria.
It is designed to bridge the gap
between your requirements and your code.
Acceptance criteria checks automatically
and compares the code in your pull request
to the requirements you
had in your Jira issue.
It's checking if you built
exactly what you said you would.
Now, you can catch mistakes
early with this feature,
and we've actually been
told by software teams
that it has actually
saved them a lot of time.
Secondly, we have custom instructions
that you can set up for your repos.
Now, you can teach Code Reviewer
exactly what matters to your organization,
to your team, to your codebase.
Now, every team has unique ways of working
and different standards
that they want to enforce,
and sometimes generic
code just doesn't cut it.
So, if you teach Code
Reviewer certain standards,
design principles,
and you feed that to Rovo Dev,
every time your pull request is created,
what will happen is Rovo Dev will detect
based on these standards
that you are violating those principles.
It is described in your
standard natural language,
so just write in English, plain English.
And as long as you commit
that into your repo,
you should be good to go.
Now, we've also launched Rovo Dev in Jira.
It is very soon coming to open beta.
Temporarily it's in beta, closed beta,
but it is a self-contained
AI-driven workflow
that helps you tackle work
items with efficiency.
And let's have a look at a demo.
Let's have a look at Rovo Dev in Jira.
What this means is you'll
be able to trigger Rovo Dev
directly from your Jira issue,
and even do that at once
for number of your Jira
tickets from the backlog.
What it does, it opens
up an interactive sandbox
that looks and feels like VS Code
directly within your Jira issue.
Now, everything happens autonomously,
which means Rovo Dev
will work on your issue,
it will create a pull request,
and it will let you know
when there is something for you to review.
It will also update the
status of that Jira ticket
if obviously you're the owner.
Now, the benefits of this
is at any point in time,
you can also go back
and look at all the sessions
that you've triggered
with Rovo Dev within Jira.
Only you have access to this sandbox
because it feeds off of your credentials,
so security is in place.
Now, what actually happens,
this opens up a chat with Rovo Dev.
If you're not happy with what you see,
the changes that it made,
you can go back and give it some feedback.
And I do encourage you to
give it back some feedback
if you're not happy with what it's done.
Ask it to make more changes.
Why not?
Once you are ready with
everything that it's produced,
you can go and create a pull request,
and this is the stuff
that I told you about,
having access to all of
your sessions at all times.
We've also brought Rovo
Dev extension into VS Code.
So, it's...
Actually, let's get to
the video immediately
and then I can walk you
through what it actually does.
Internet is better this time, let's go.
So connecting your Atlassian cloud side
will instantly pull all your Jira tickets
that you are assigned to,
whether it's in to-do,
progress or in review.
Now, you can start
working on a Jira issue.
Ah, internet is not on my side today.
So you can start working
on your Jira issue
directly from the VS Code.
What it does is it will open up
Rovo Chat
and you can just tell it
what kind of stuff you want it to do,
attaching the Jira issue to it.
It will also send you notifications
if anyone has made changes
to the Jira tickets
that you are following or working on.
So, if you are working from
the VS Code with Rovo Dev,
you will be getting
notifications at all times.
So very similar to Rovo Dev in Jira,
very similar to Rovo Dev in CLI,
you can talk to Rovo Dev from VS Code.
We are working on adding that
to JetBrains, stay tuned.
Now, productivity for software teams
is increased through automation
in Rovo Dev's Code Reviewer.
Automation rules may be created
to review pull requests or generate code.
Is anyone else experiencing
poor internet today?
A lot of us are.
Okay, great.
I'm not alone, I'm not...
Okay, I'm not alone in
everyone experiencing.
Okay, we're just gonna
have to roll with it, guys.
So, with Rovo Dev in automations,
you can enforce organizational
code quality standards
across teams and repos.
So imagine all those code
standards that you wanna enforce,
now you can apply to more
than just one codebase,
you can apply to all of your workspaces.
You can also delegate
repetitive tasks at scale,
letting your team focus on important work.
Now, once you set up your coding,
security, privacy, or design standards,
you can use Rovo Dev
to automatically review
every pull request
against those standards.
You can also enter custom instructions
for Rovo Dev to use when
reviewing your pull request,
like I've done just here.
And similarly, you can
define common coding patterns
and use Rovo Dev to
automatically generate code
for repetitive tasks.
So, it lives in Jira in multiple ways.
You can automate pretty much anything.
Now, I'm literally demoing
the stuff that I've asked it to do
and identify all the sort of logging
non-compliance standards
that we don't allow,
and it's actually done and
told me about the violation.
We've also launched the
Rovo Dev in pipelines
in Bitbucket Cloud as part of Rovo Dev.
It diagnoses and resolves CI/CD pipelines,
all the failures
and analyzes those failed
builds through steps
and provides root causes,
suggesting actionable fixes.
Actually, the more you
use Rovo Dev in pipelines,
the better it gets
because it will learn about
your failed builds each time.
So instead of manually
digging through your logs,
the troubleshooter surfaces
that context for you
directly in Bitbucket Cloud.
Now, how does Rovo Dev
actually stand out from all
the other AI coding assistants?
Apart from not only being
an AI coding assistant,
but it does help with all the other 84%
of software development lifecycle tasks
that I know no one really wants to do.
Well, Rovo Dev uniquely connects to Jira,
Confluence, Bitbucket, but also GitHub,
providing context aware insights
across your entire tool chain,
leveraging the Teamwork Graph
that connects your
Atlassian Ecosystem data.
Secondly, it is an AI-powered automation
across the software development lifecycle.
So, unlike tools that focus on only code,
Rovo Dev does a lot more.
Secondly, it is a terminal-first
context-rich experience,
which means it is designed
to meet you wherever you are working,
in the IDE, in the CLI,
in Jira, and in the CI/CD pipelines.
And it is enterprise grade
security and customization.
It lets teams customize workflows,
set review standards,
but also tailor AI behavior.
Thank you so much for listening.
If you do have any questions,
I will be right behind.
Also, I'm at the Atlassian booth,
and there's a lot more demos
I can do than just this one.
Thank you all for coming,
and thank you all for being patient.